Mais t'es cinglé !
Les gars, mais où est-ce qu’ils vont chercher tout ça?
Mais je vous ai déjà vu, vous êtes le mec qui joue…
Rassurez-vous, tout ceci est du cinéma,
Corentin est un acteur.
Vous vous demandez,
«Où est-ce qu’ils vont chercher tout ça»?
Suivez-moi!
Nous voici dans les locaux de Studio Bag...
De Golden Moustache.
Golden Moustache, c’est avant tout des sketchs.
Et quel meilleur endroit pour commencer la visite...
Que la salle des auteurs.
À ce moment-là, il referme sa main.
Et Il l’écrase.
C’est très méta!
Ca bosse.
La salle du directeur.
La salle technique.
La salle des tigres.
(rugissements)
Mauvais investissement,
on a très peu de sketchs avec des tigres.
Nous voici à présent dans la salle des effets spéciaux.
C’est ici que le merveilleux prend vie.
Comme par exemple,...
Un petit moineau.
Un petit moineau dans ma main.
Golden Moustache,
c’est avant tout un site internet.
Oui?
Oui, bonjour,
excusez-moi de vous déranger.
En fait ça fait deux fois
que vous dites « C’est avant tout» .
Du coup je me dis que c’est pas très logique,
parce que ça fait une sorte de…
Alors vous allez me dire:
« Qu'est ce qu'il a de spécial
ce site internet ? »
Sur www.goldenmoustache.com,
vous pouvez voir les sketchs
24h avant leur sortie sur Youtube.
Et si vous souscrivez au compte
Premium Rétroactif VIP +,
(coups de feu)
vous pouvez voir les sketchs
avant même qu’ils soient tournés.
(cris)
Par contre là, il faut imaginer
que là évidemment il y a des pouvoirs,
parce que c’est de la post production, moi je vole.
C’est vraiment ça Golden Moustache?
Je m'envole !
Ouais, enfin, ils travaillent dessus, là.
Mais c’est de la merde.
C’est également sur le site que
vous trouverez en exclusivité les vidéos du Lab.
Ici, on expérimente, on teste
les nouvelles idées, les nouvelles blagues.
Sans thunes.
Du coup, la vidéo,
ce serait une parodie de Game of Thrones,
mais, avec de la mie de pain.
Tu peux me rappeler ton prénom s’il te plaît?
Yannick.
D’accord Yannick.
(cris et rugissements de tigres)
Mais Golden Moustache,
c’est avant tout du contenu original,
des articles, des montages hilarants, des makings of.
D’ailleurs en ce moment-même,
nous sommes en train de tourner
le making of de cette vidéo.
Mais nous tournons également
le making of du making  of,
du making of,
du making of.
Arrêtez de bouger putain!
En plus du contenu exclusif,
vous trouverez le meilleur d’internet
sélectionné par notre prospecteur d’humour digital:
l’irremplaçable Pierre Trapu.
Merci Dimitri.
Nous avec des copains, on a mis une caméra,
on a pris une musique, et chacun son tour…
Attends, attends, c’est un libdub?
Oui.
Tu dégages.
Non, pas un chat encore!
(miaulement)
Non mais c’est bon,
je vais le prendre.
goldenmoustache.com, c’est enfin et avant tout
une plateforme participative
ou chacun et chacune peut proposer du contenu,
comme par exemple des montages !
Avec du gros dubstep de bâtard.
Bienvenue dans cette troisième saison.
Avec un nouveau site, et des tigres.